foreign
[Music]
my name is Rohan razaki I'm a PhD
candidate in the lab of Dr Winston temp
at Johns Hopkins University Department
of biomedical engineering and I want to
thank the organizers of this event for
inviting me to talk to you today about
one of our projects measurement of DNA
methylation and laminate Associated
domains using nanopore sequencing
so before uh we dive into the nanopore
sequencing part of it I just wanted to
quickly refresh our memories uh water
lamina Associated domains or Labs these
are genomic regions that are in close
proximity of the nuclear lamina uh they
are relatively uh quite large regions
um somewhere between uh 10 kilobases up
to 10 megabases in the typical mammalian
cell
and as sort of expected from The
observed height Association of condensed
Coumadin with the nuclear lamina
Lads do possess several molecule
features uh that I am showing on the
right right hand side table of this
presentation that are typical of
heterochromatin uh for example most
genes in leads are transcriptionally
silent or expressed at low levels and
also they overlap with the regions that
usually replicate uh very late during
the S phase
um and another feature that we are
interested in uh are the fact that lead
are enriched for histone modifications
that are typical
heterochromotion as well
um usually these regions are identified
uh using the technology called Dam ID
um
so what is that might be damn ID is a
technique that in which we are using
these bacterial DNA atom and metal
transferase or called Dam that deposits
m6a uh in a sequencing context of gatc
motifs
um and this technique is not unique only
for looking at lamina as a safe demands
it could be used to look at any sort of
DNA protein interactions studies and the
way that we do that is basically we're
using these uh dynamical transfers it to
a person of interest here typically
being any laminate person simply being
as lamin B1 here uh and then we have the
stable expression of this constant into
your cell lines and
then from there you would have the
position of uh m6a into your any DNA
that is in close proximity of the
nuclear lamina uh this base
modifications are usually
visualized by microscopy or is or they
can be investigated using a high
throughput Illumina sequencing with
enrichment of
methylated DNA fragments by using
a variety of methylation ever
restriction digestion and PCR
now that I told you about uh what that
Mighty is uh in our lab we do a lot of
nanopore sequencing and we do a lot of
long wave sequencing technology
so one of the main questions that we had
was that can we adapt this technology
this method to Long reason more
specifically Nano for sequencing so I'm
going to give you a very brief overview
of nanopore sequencing here and
nanoparticipanting we have a biological
nanopore protein that sits into a
biolipid membrane as I'm showing it on
the lower left hand side
and we're applying voltage current
across this
I bilipid membrane and we're passing a
single strand of DNA or RNA
at a control speed of translocation
using a helicase
and this speed of transformation is
usually around 450 bases per second for
DNA and about 75 pages per second for a
native RNA molecule
and as these uh strands of uh DNA or RNA
passing through the pore they are
blocking uh the current that in a unique
way that is dependent of the sequencing
context of that specific uh k-mer which
is typically five or six mirrors
um and then from these unique current
disruptions as I'm showing in the table
in the in the plot in the middle uh we
can interior the sequence of the DNA or
RNA molecule that was passed through the
poor
now there are a lot of advantages and
disadvantages to this technique but one
of the advantages that we are
particularly very interested in is that
we can look at uh DNA or RNA based
modifications
and uh we can do this because we are
essentially looking at electrical raw
data since fear these modestines so
we're not limited to any to canonical
bases but we can look at any sort of
epigenetic or if transcriptomic changes
in the nucleic acids
um and here I'm showing two example Uh
current distributions uh on the for the
plot on the left uh we are looking at
the DNA motif of TGG ACG that is shown
in the plaque and it's uh
camera that has the 5mc methylation in
red and we're looking at the current
distribution and we can see that there's
a clear significant shift to the right
when we are having the the 5mc
methylation and
through the work of our lab and other uh
groups around the world uh it has been
already shown that we can call 5mc
methylation very robustly using the
nanopore sequencing platform
um
but when we're looking at the similar
comparison and what is relatively new on
the right side uh focusing on the m6
aimet question we can see that the shift
in the signal
is there but it's not as nearly as
strong as what we observe usually with
the 5mc so what I'm trying to show here
is that I understand that this is a
small example but what I'm trying to
show here is the fact that calling m6a
using nanopore sequencing is a much
harder and challenging task than 5mc
column
now there are
a variety of tools that we can use to
call methylation uh using nanoper data
we're usually using two tools in our lab
one is called Megalodon which has been
developed by Marcus cyber at ont
which uses a neural network based models
to call Base modifications
and we also use nanopolish that was
developed by Jared Simpson collaborative
in a
that uses a hidden markup model based
algorithm to call Face modifications
now that we're using these tools uh one
of the main questions that we had was
which one performs better how did it
compare so what we did is we generate
the ROC curve uh the my lab made
actually generated Vincent's hand
um what we're showing here is on the
x-axis false positive rates and the
y-axis true positive rate and just for
the second just focusing on the cpg
calls that are shown in red and
nanopolish calls on uh show shows with
the solid line and the middle one calls
with the dashed line we can see that cpg
calls for both of these software are
very well called and we can confirm that
by looking at the table area under the
care or AUC we can see that the cpg
calls for both now because Omega are
0.92 and 0.94 respectively but when
we're looking at them
we can see that the megalon calls are
outperforming nanoplas calls pretty
significantly and the AOC AUC calls are
0.68 for nanopology that's 0.86 for
Megalodon
and
this could be due to various reasons uh
and I we think that we need uh better
training sets and better algorithms to
call these n6a methylations in in a
better way
but the main question here is that is
this good enough for us to be able to
call last and look at laminate
Associated domains using nanopore
sequencing
and for that uh we performed a pilot
experiment with a collaboration of uh Dr
what boss Filson in Netherlands and the
outline of this experiment is that we
use a haploid cell lines have one cells
that have the stable expression of these
damn lamin be1 constructs then we
selected these cells at the early stages
of essays
and we perform both a conventional Dam
ID as well as
nanopore sequencing and then we wanted
to look at comparative analysis of cpg
calls and damp methylation calls using
the two software that I mentioned
earlier
and
just looking at one example here uh
percent manipulation called across the
chromosome 10.
nanopolish calls are shown at the top
middle and calls are shown at the bottom
the rest curve shows cpg methylation
percentage and the blue curve shows Dam
methylation percentage here and
the
pink rectangles here shows the lads that
their items by using the conventional
Dam ID sequencing using Illuminati
sequencing
um what we can see immediately here is
that we do see a shift uh in the
methylation called inside the lats
there's a hyperventilation of dam
methylation as expected and there's a
hypo methylation of cpg called inside
the labs just to
show this in a sort of a better way I'm
focusing on one of the regions here so
we can showcase this better megalon
calls are shown on the left side and now
polish code on the right side we can
again see these sort of sharp increase
in uh Dam methylation inside the lab and
uh the hypermethylation of cpg calls
inside that which is uh consistent with
the current literature that exists on
this specific cell line
um what is also really interesting here
that we can see a sharper increase in
the middle and cause rather than
nanopological which is sort of explicit
because I already showed you that
Megalodon has a better empathy calling
then not a Polish
now
what I'm showing here is
um
basically the same result that I showed
in the previous slide but in a more
um you know white manner
uh when we are looking at them
methylation calls at the top
uh we can see that for both Megalodon
and nanopolish calls we see
significantly higher methylation rates
uh inside the lab versus outside the
labs now
the point that I want to emphasis here
is that we don't really know the true
methylation rate
of them ID assays it has up until now we
have been relying on enrichment methods
and PCR to sort of detect these
methylation rates but with single
molecule assay like nanopore sequencing
we could potentially look at the true
methylation rate assuming that we can
achieve
a robust methylation calling asgarden
and sulfur but
just looking at these results we do
expect that this true manipulation rate
be somewhere between four or five
percent up to uh
20 percent
and similarly when we're looking at cpg
modulation at the bottom
we can see that uh the both of Mega and
non-polished calls are hypermethylated
inside the lab and
we do see a little bit of discrepancy
when we are looking at the inside Lads
for nanopolish between a noun push club
and middle one called and Milan is
calling uh less of a methylation
percentage than nanopolish and color we
are investing in this further to see if
there's any biases associated with any
uh tumors uh
and lastly
uh what I wanted to focus on is to look
at the edges of the glass as we know
that uh these edges are
enriched with a lot of different uh DNA
important interactions such as ctcf
binding sites so they are very important
for our purpose
um and at the bot at the top I'm showing
the damn methylation calls again uh
middle level in Blue uh Nano polish and
uh
red and and the lab boundaries are shown
in pink and we can see as we're moving
from uh outside of the legs to inside we
see this sharp increase in manipulation
calls uh which is very interesting
because now we can see that uh
and identify these uh edges with a
better resolution as you can see that I
I reduce the spinning size here to 10 KB
from 100 KB to have a better resolution
and we do see that dip in in the uh
methylation percentage
exact at the edges of the last and what
we think
uh as Happening Here is that because the
edges of the lat are enriched in cpcf
binding side so the the methylation
rates for both damage and cpg metals
should be lower than outside and inside
of the lab and that's all we're
observing here
um and similar with the cpg mutation at
the bottom we can see that as we're
moving inside the lat region we see the
increase the decrease in methylation
costs
and this has been a pretty much a work
in progress we are working on a lot of
different things to expand on this assay
and this method uh we're incorporating
habitat phasing into the current
analysis uh and obviously for that we
are moving into a typical cell line and
we are moving away from uh have one
cells
um and as we know that uh long with
sequencing one of the advantages of it
is that we can phase everything to
different alleles uh way more robustly
than shortward sequence so we want to
take advantage of that and look at
hopefully
any a little specific lamina Associated
domains interactions
um and another thing that we're working
on is to enhance the performance
automation clock as I said earlier we
need to generate better training sets so
we are focusing on uh genomes that have
a better chamber representation so we
would end up with a better
training set and ultimately better
methylation calling
um
what we are also focusing right now is
on is that that we want to call these
lats and differentially methylation
region methylated regions solely Based
on nanopore data we don't want to do uh
Commission on damn ID anymore
and for to do that we are looking at a
variety of different algorithms such as
circular binary segmentation algorithms
to identify these regions robustly just
based on along with data and lastly what
I didn't get the chance to talk to them
uh in my presentation today is the use
of hotspot sequencing we know that
Pacquiao sequencing is very robust and
very accurate in called m6a methylation
so we want to also take advantage take
advantage of that and compare with ont
and conventional Dam ID data and to see
how bitter the pack biosequencing is in
calling m6a methylation than the other
two platforms here
and with that uh I wanna
thank all the members of the temp lab
our collaborative boss and Don and also
any gri for their support and funding of
this study thank you